[Music]
the content which language has he
required is no longer the perverted
and perverting and distracted self of
the world of culture
on the contrary it is the spirit that
has returned into itself
is certain of itself and certain in
itself
of its truth or of its own recognition
of that truth and which is acknowledged
as knowing it the language of the
ethical spirit
is law and simple command and complaint
which is more the shedding of a tear
about necessity
moral consciousness on the other hand is
still dumb
shut up within itself within its inner
life for there the self does not as yet
have an existence
existence and the self stand as yet only
in an external relation
to each other language however only
emerges as the middle term mediating
between independent and acknowledged
self-consciousness
and the existent self is immediately
universal acknowledgement
and acknowledgement on the part of many
and in this manifold-ness a simple
acknowledgement
the content of the language of
conscience is the self that knows itself
as essential being this alone is what it
declares
and this declaration is the true
actuality of the act
and the validating of the action
consciousness
declares its conviction it is in this
conviction alone that the action is a
duty
also it is valid as duty solely through
the conviction
being declared for universal
self-consciousness
is free from the specific action that
merely is
what is valid for that
self-consciousness is not the action
as an existence but the conviction that
it is a duty
and this is made actual in language to
make the deed a reality does not mean
here
translating its content from the form of
purpose or being for self
into the form of an abstract reality it
means
translating it from the form of
immediate self-certainty
which knows its knowledge or being for
self to be essential being
into the form of an assurance that
consciousness is convinced of its duty
and as conscience knows in its own mind
what duty is this assurance thus
affirms that consciousness is convinced
that its conviction
is the essence of the matter
paragraph 653 begins with some
contrast between how language is being
used
at this point of the phenomenology in
this morality section near the end
of spirit and how it had been used
earlier for self-consciousness in some
earlier stages of the same
massive development of the spirit
section
and what we've got going on here before
we jump into the text is actually
quite interesting to think about we can
say that there's
a general complaint that gets made
throughout the ages and it goes all the
way back to
early considerations of language in
western philosophy
for example in in plato's discussions in
the cradles
and you could say even further in the
pre-socratic philosophers
like parmenides and heraclitus but also
in those who are examining the
poetic texts that are being put forth i
suppose you could say all three of those
philosophers are actually not just
poets themselves in a certain way but
also anti-poets as well
and so the basic complaint is is this
why can't people just say
precisely what they mean or precisely
what reality is why does language
which is this universal medium
of exchange which should say how things
truly are or at least say how they
appear to us
or at least express our own true
inner selves why does language
not just conceal actually here is a
great place to bring up the heraclition
god the the god of delphi who doesn't
simply conceal or
hide away but doesn't simply make clear
and manifest but signals by way of signs
signs that have to then be interpreted
why can't language be straightforward
like like in the ideas like everything
else now
if we're good followers of hegel
at this point we know that nothing is as
straightforward as it appears right
everything is subject to the dialectic
you might say the natural world
less so you know hegel's philosophy of
nature was
was not a rousing success and and
you know it's rightly set aside at this
point in time
but when it comes to the cultural world
the world that we
inhabit and the world in which we
rise up within the world in which we
actually have culture
building development it is the case that
nothing is unmediated nothing is as
simple as it seems you never get
something completely straightforward
there's always more to dig
into isn't there and so hegel
is bringing up something here that we
might say
is a temptation a will of the wisp
you know this thing that's perpetually
eluding us
leading us deeper into the forest where
we get lost and then it disappears and
we're like
how the hell did we get here right
the idea is that at some point in time
we can all be
as we say in american english straight
shooters right we can all
express exactly what's going on and this
is in fact a dream a desire something
that we hunger for
but something that's going to turn out
to be unavailable
and we can look back from the vantage
point
of where we've arrived here in the
phenomenology
at previous uses or invocations
of language by hegel in earlier parts
of the development of spirit
this this entire spirit section and say
oh it didn't happen then and we might
think about others as well
we could think back to the unhappy
consciousness and all the attempts to
use not just language but ritual
and symbology to bridge this gap between
the
the unimportant individual and the
universal that's way out there we could
think of
other uses within the reason section
you know talking about laws the law of
the heart
reason giving itself laws none of those
actually managed to
to make it all the way through but they
did advance us a bit
and realizing that there's there's this
other stuff going on with language that
we
saw in the past at points where we
thought
that language would give us a pure
meaning
a uncontroversial way of looking at
things
we we can say yes this this was not
exactly what we wanted remember too that
this is going to be brought along
these remain functions of language or
possibilities of language
especially this language of culture as
we're going to see a little bit later on
but we're trying to get past that
so all of that some some preamble
hegel says the content which language
has here acquired what it is
that language can say it's got a new
content a new
in halt in german is no longer
the perverted and perverting
and distracted self
of the world of culture of
building right and building by the way
doesn't just mean culture in the sense
of like high culture it also means
education right
it means development all these attempts
that
in previous stages the person the
developing
self by opposition to its society
had to try to to change itself to make
itself into something better
these have become perverted these are
also perverting
that's why there's a reaction against
the enlightenment
and distracted self a self that
winds up going nowhere you could say
right there's the the frenzy that that
comes with this and we've seen this at
several different points as well right
uh this is a good place in the narrative
of the phenomenology
to think about the earlier stages as
being kind of unfolded or if we want to
use hegel's own term
al hoben right uh and fold it in and and
the essential moments preserved we have
this going on
in the conscious the self-consciousness
section right with skepticism
we have this going on in the reasons
section we have this going on
in the spirit section and so we're
leaving that part of language behind
because now we have a better we have a
better content
this by the way ought to put us on our
guard right because
if hegel's focusing on content here you
know that he's soon going to be talking
about the form
and how the form is not exactly mapping
on to the content but let's just leave
that aside
and enjoy our little time of peace
and rest and optimism for a moment so
we're getting past
that he says on the contrary it is the
spirit
that has returned into itself is
certain of itself and certain in itself
of its truth or of its own
recognition of that truth and which is
acknowledged as
knowing it isn't that great you know
all the hegelian categories not all of
them of course but but
quite a few of them are coming together
in a harmonious way at this point let's
look at that line one more time and
think through its implications the sp it
is the spirit that has returned
into itself right so there has been a
development there's been a movement
now it's certain of itself that's one of
the key things that the hegelian spirit
is always looking for isn't it
certainty give his height and certain in
itself
of its truth not only does it have
certainty give his height it also has
truth var height can these two be
successfully brought together
at this point now of course if you've
been traveling along the path of the
phenomenology
up until this point you know that the
answer is going to be no
that that right now we we have something
going on
that will um
turn out to be a little bit illusory a
little bit
of a optimistic projection
but let's follow it along still for for
the moment so
we have um it's certain of itself
in its truth and then we have some a
really interesting twist here
or of its own recognition of that truth
it doesn't just have truth and this is a
very important point
kind of flies under the radar here it
needs to recognize that
as truth as its truth
and we see this term recognition or
acknowledgement
throughout this this uh paragraph and
indeed throughout this entire section
because that is what spirit as
individual beings
has been looking for all this time
recognition
of this truth as its truth
he goes on and he says and which is
acknowledged
as knowing it so it's not the truth now
or the certainty
that's acknowledged it's the subject the
person who is acknowledged as knowing
this truth
and what that means in this case is
having a conscience having a
fully developed conscience that it acts
in relation to
and in this paragraph talks
and is talked about in relation to
so we're still not at that that point of
exactly laying out what that is we have
one more contrast to look at
what about the language of ethical
spirit
that was earlier right that was where we
had the invocation of the antigone
and all these discussions about the city
or the state
and the gods and the individual and all
that sort of sort of business
well the language of ethical spirit zit
leaking
geist now remember that that for hegel
whatever you may have read in
intro to ethics textbooks about ethics
being you know the study
of of uh what's right and wrong and
morality being just codes
that's exactly the opposite for hegel
right zit like in
ethical life is something that is less
conscious less you could say
reflexively agentic that is able to
decide for itself
it's more driving uh forces that that
are there
and it is being dominated by those and
sort of unfolding those within the scope
of the individual
or the group consciousness so ethical
spirit is where you actually have a
society
a civilization a culture that has
roots a history and where people
arise to situations of power or into
moral dilemmas
and it's driven by something outside of
themselves some necessity
that places them in there and brings
them into conflict
and he talks about three main modes of
language in that case one is law
gazettes
right there's the law of the city and
the law
of the gods or the law of the family
command but fail
those who have power get to tell other
people what to do
and both of them are you could say
members of of the spiritual ethical
community
right they may not always follow but
that is that is one of the possibilities
and then we have complaint
it's interesting that he brings this up
because what that means is that there's
a pushback there's
it's not just power and and language
flows from on
from on high from on top down and
everybody accepts it
rather there's there's a push back
there's a yes okay fine i'll do your
thing
but and then antigone doesn't
do what she's supposed to or her sister
wavers back and forth as many
about whether she should give in to
power or whether she should line herself
up with antigone and we could go on and
on with all sorts of examples of that
hegel is saying that this is also being
left behind
as well and now why is it being left
behind
so he tells us the language of the
ethical spirit
is these things and he says complaint is
more
the shedding of a tear about necessity
moral consciousness
on the other hand is still dumb shut up
with itself within its inner life for
there the self does not as yet
have an existence existence and the self
stand as yet only in an external
relationship to
each other so there's something that's
lacking
in development there however complex it
may be
however interesting it may be there's
something that has not yet been attained
and hegel thinks that this
is something that has been attained in
modernity specifically
in western modernity right so there's
there's something that has been
developed and it has to do with language
so he tells us
that language emerges as the middle
term we're going to come back to this in
a bit
you notice i've placed it a little bit
lower on the board
in part because i think that what's
going on here is is what's more
driving it and then this is what is
actually achieved
in it so let's run through that passage
language emerges as the middle term
mediating between independent and
acknowledged self uh
you know uh here we go acknowledge
self-consciousness right so it's
sign in both cases and the existence
self is immediately
universal acknowledgement and
acknowledgement on the part of many
and in this manifoldness a simple
acknowledgement
the content of the language of
conscience is the self that knows itself
as essential being that is what the new
content is the self
that knows itself as essential being as
you could say the center
of its linguistic and uh
action and duty universe every single
person and this is why this for hegel
has to wait
until modernity right in modernity any
individual
person potentially can become the center
of spirit and act according to that or
at least
understand itself as such doesn't mean
that everybody can
grab the reins of the state or the
rudder of the state whatever metaphor we
want to use
but it does mean that everybody has
access
to the reflexivity of spirit through
language through the development of of
culture through having gone through
these things
so he goes on and he says
the content of language right this alone
is what it declares this alone
the self that knows itself as the
central being this new content
is what it declares
and this declaration is as he says the
true
actuality of the act and the validating
of the action
declares could also be expressed as
expressing right or as
literally saying saying outwardly saying
to
something uh not just itself but it is
also
for itself right so declares what does
it declare
the true actuality of the act the vara
virkliquite des twins and the validating
of the action
galtender handling we've talked about
this before and actually i just talked
about it in the last few paragraphs
that han lung and and tot or tun
are not exactly the same thing we should
think of one
as sort of uh occasional or punctual you
do an action an act right and then there
is
action which would be composed of of
many acts but would also include sort of
the broader you know motivation habits
that you've developed we could think of
it as
as not just action but also
as comportment if that helps you think
about it in a
you know more lasting term so we have
the true actuality of the
act the the the reality the viewer
clique kite
of the act and then we have the
validating the saying that it does
have value or validity
of the action itself and this is what is
being declared
by the self that knows itself as an
essential being
this is very abstract so what are we
talking about here
so in behaving according to
say some some moral guideline like love
thy neighbor as thyself by
deciding to make that central in one's
own
han lung in one's action and then
actually go you know take a casserole
over to your neighbor
who has had a death in the family and
meet them at the door
and say i didn't want you to have to
cook this is kind of a
custom here in the united states and
particularly in the midwest
when somebody dies you get fed a lot by
your neighbors
that's that's and family that's just the
way it goes
and that can be the expression of
self knowing itself as a central being
saying
i'm a good person this is the right
thing to do i'm going to do this
and if you can't you know make a
casserole well you go and buy a
casserole at you know some
deli or something like that and bring it
to them now in doing so we have a very
particular
case that we're looking at but this is
looked at by the person who's doing it
as
a way in which they declare
what they're doing they express
now he goes on a little bit further
and let's get a little bit more
complicated here he says that
this alone is what it declares
the declaration is the true actuality
the act of the validating of the action
consciousness declares its conviction
right it declares what it thinks
what it is convinced by
what it it
follows you know it's kind of
interesting we use this word conviction
as something that you have
typically about outside affairs like i
it's my conviction
that we need to do something about the
many people who are going to be homeless
when they're not able to pay their rent
in the middle of a pandemic right
but we can also talk about conviction as
inward and
it's interesting that among protestant
christians
of certain types they will talk about
being convicted
by say the word that they're reading
meaning the
the religious scriptures and
conviction means a sense of
responsibility
oftentimes that you haven't met your
responsibilities
so in this case it's not that way it's a
conviction
that one is doing the right thing that
one
is the bearer of moral rectitude
and so the conviction he says here right
the consciousness declares its
conviction
he says it is in this conviction alone
that the action is a duty so it's not
that there's some sort of
imperious outside norms that come in
and say thou shalt thou shalt not
or some calculation on a utilitarian
basis of
you know what is to the general benefit
of the community and
we have to follow that no it's the
individual
who has decided that the action is duty
and precisely because they've decided
for themselves
that they are going to follow these
moral norms or make these moral norms
valid the action does become
duty right the han lung
becomes flicked so
it's not that flicked or duty is
something outside of ourselves we
discover it
and we don't just like look within oh
there it is there's duty i better follow
this
it's something that we think over and
decide on
so he goes on and he says that it's
valid
it's in this conviction alone and the
action is a duty it is
also it is valid as duty solely
through the conviction being declared so
there is a
it's not just that you you decide for
yourself and then you go and do the
thing
you communicate about it there is also
a sense in which the conviction
being expressed allows that action to be
duty
so this is very complexly connected
isn't it and
here we should take a little pause and
go outside of the text a little bit
and think about some of the implications
of this
the fact that i'm expressing it means
that i am placing it
out there in language in this medium
that
all these other people share all these
other self-consciousnesses
and i cannot actually compel them to see
things exactly the way that i do
can i i'm hoping they do at this point
i'm assuming they do
because that's how i can say i'm the
good guy here right
but that's not necessarily going to be
the case
so he goes on and he says universal
self-consciousness
is free from the specific action that
merely is in this case bringing the
casserole
what is valid for that
self-consciousness is not the action as
an existence
but the conviction that it is a duty and
this is made actual in language
i bring the casserole to the door of the
bereaved person
and i say here you go i didn't want i
didn't want you to have to cook for
yourself i'm so sorry for your loss
and then my neighbor is looking at me
and my neighbor is like oh that's a good
guy right there
now if i'd handed it to them in silence
and just nodded
maybe it wouldn't have the same effect
if i handed it to them and i was like
there you go right and i say it in kind
of a demeaning way
not the same effect
i'm displaying myself as a
good person to the others
and thereby to myself in language
so he says to make the deed a reality
does not mean here translating its
content from the form of purpose
or being for self into the form of an
abstract reality
it means translating it from the form of
immediate self certainty which knows its
knowledge or being for self to be
essential being
into the form of an assurance that
consciousness
is convinced of its duty i'm a good
person i'm convinced of my duty right
and as conscience knows in its own mind
what duty is
so i'm not confused about what duty is
and this is where it gets pretty dicey
right because there's all sorts of
things that people do and they're like
oh i was doing this for you
i i'm really trying to help you out and
you're like you prick
you did exactly the opposite of what i
what i would actually want
because you never pay attention and
you're you're giving me something i
actually don't want
and that's getting in the way of me
actually getting something that would be
helpful for me get the hell out of here
right
that's a possibility for consciousness
but
conscience doesn't realize this at this
point
we're going to see that emerge a little
bit later so he he concludes by saying
that
the this assurance affirms that
consciousness is convinced that its
conviction is the essence of the matter
now that's very very
formal at this point so
we're going to come back to that in just
a sec but i do want to jump back up to
the the part where he's talking about
language
as a mediating term so he says language
emerges as the middle term
mediating between what independent
uh self stendinger right
uh subs poverstein and acknowledged
honor counter supps before sign
so it's it's bringing those two together
which would otherwise be sundered and
the existence self he says is
immediately
universal acknowledgement and
acknowledgement on the part of many
that's that's a long-winded
circumlocution that miller is using for
just saying uh it's multifold it's
manifold it's
it's a manic faulty gut right and um
it's a feel height a plurality
and he says that in this manifoldness a
simple acknowledgement
right so all of this is happening
by way of language language is the
medium
that allows us to do this and allows
the person the person of conscience
to convince him or herself
in some respect that they're a better
person a simpler person
an acknowledged person everybody's with
me everybody
understands me than they actually are
but that is what has been achieved at
this point in time
taking us beyond the other uses
of language earlier in the spirit
section